متواجدا على متن سفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل
هذه الفرقاطه
العسكريه التي يبلغ طولها 106 امتار
وعرضها سته عشره مترا هذه فرقاط العسكريه
المجهزه بكافه الاسلحه المتقدمه والتي
خصصتها القوات البحريه السعوديه لاجراء
عمليات الاجلاء من ميناء بورت السودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل هنا بجده سوف نرافق هذه
السفينه الى ميناء بورد السودان من متوقع
وصولنا في تمامه بعد ثم من ثمانيه الى عشر
ساعات هي مده الرحله البحريه وصولا الى
ميناء بورت السودان لاجلاء الرعايه بمختلف
جنسيتهم كما نشاهد تجهيزات كبيره على متن
هذه السفينه سوف تستوعب اكثر من 65 شخص من
الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهم فور وصولها الى
ميناء بورت السودان العربيه سوف
نعم
طيب انقطعت الصوره وصوت كذلك ولكن سنشترك
بعض لحظات ربما نعود لاستكمال هذا الشرح
التفصيل لزميلنا سلطاننا السلمي عاده
الصوره اعود لك من جديد سلطان تفضل
نعم هذه امامكم هذه القمره هي القمره
القياده المخصصه لعمليه
بالسفينه نتحدث انه من المتوقع خلال
الساعات خلال الساعه ثمانيه ساعات او عشر
ساعات القادمه سوف نصل الى الميناء بورت
سودان سوف تكون هذه هي السفينه السابعه
فيما يتعلق بعمليات التي بدات منذ قرابه
الاربعه ايامنا في السعوديه اذا كما
تحدثنا هي مجهزه بعتاد عسكري باعلى جوده
كما يظهر امامكم للامام الكاميرا قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه التي ابحرنا منها قبل
دقائق معدوده فور او وصول هذه الفرقاط
العسكريه الى ميناء بورد سودان سوف تتم
عمليات الاجلاء على متنها وسوف تستوعب
اكثر من خمسه وستين شخص سيحدث على
امكانيات كبيره سوف نرافق هذه الفرقاط
العسكريه حتى وصولها الى ميناء السودان
نتحدث عن امكانيات كبيره لهذه الفرقات
العسكريه لحمايه كافه الرعايه التي سوف
يكونون على
متنها ايضا فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء في
التي تعمل عليها السعوديه بالتنسيق مع
كافه الاطراف هناك في السودان نعم نظرا
لاننا يعني بدانا في عمليات البحار لذلك
تضعف الشبكه بشكل واضح وكبير اثناء دخولنا
الى المياه البحر الاحمر لكنه اؤكد انه
هذه السفينه هي السفينه
القوات السعوديه التي تعمل
في عمليات الاجلاء الخاصه بالرعايه
الاجانب والمواطنين السعوديين من بورت
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحرين
نتحدث على اعداد وبلغت اكثر من 2020 شهر
من ثمانيه عملت على اجلاهم الحكومه
السعوديه منذ بدء الازمه وتحديدا بدات
عمليات الاجلاء خلال ثلاثه ايام الماضيه
واخر التحديثات فيما يتعلق بعد وصول
الرعايه لنتحدث انه استقبلت الحكومه
السعوديه اليوم او قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه اكبر عمليه اجلاء منذ بدء الازمه
في السودان نتحدث عن عدد ليصل الى 1667
شخص من اكثر من اربعين الجنسيه استقبل
اليوم قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه على وهم
على متن سفينه تجاريه تسمى امانه سوف نزود
كافه المعلومات خاصه بعمليات الاجلاء وما
وكيف هي عمليات التنسيق على ارض الميدان
الفقره القادمه ايضا يتحدث انه فيما يتعلق
بعمليات الانسانيه التي تعمل عليها
الحكومه السعوديه هي تراعي بطبيعه الحال
كافه العمليات الانسانيه والمواقف
الانسانيه في ظل الازمات الكبيره التي
يعيشها الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم هناك في
السودان نعم بعد الوصول الى بورتسودان
والاكيد بانك كنت على متن سفن اخرى او على
الاقل تابعت سلطان مراحل عمليات الاجلاء
كيف ستتم العمليه ما الذي خصصته المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ما هي الجهه التي
ستوكل لها عمليه مساعده الرعايه
وعمليه مساعدتهم طبعا لصعودهم الى هذه
السفينه ومن ثم التوجه من جديد والعوده من
جديد الى جده كيف ستتم ما الاجراءات وما
هي التفاصيل الاضافيه عند وصولكم الى بورت
سودان
هذه الفرقاطه سفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل
المتوقع خلال عشر الساعات القادمه سوف نصل
الى الميناء بورت سودان سوف العربيه سوف
تنزل على ارض وسوف نزور مقرات التنسيق
للحكومه السعوديه وكيف سوف تتم عمليات
النقل من الخرطوم الى بورسودان ومن ثم الى
السفن العسكريه السعوديه التابعه للقوات
البحريه السعوديه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات